okay so I think we should be live now
and um welcome everyone to the diffusion
models uh live event this is part of um
a course that we're offering
um with uh Jonathan Whitaker and um I'm
really excited uh today we're going to
have a range of speakers from the
creators disabled diffusion to David ha
from stability AI to Devi from met Ai
and several other people so if you've
got any burning questions about I don't
know schedulers or noise or anything
like this about diffusion models today
is the chance to ask them
and my name is Lewis I'm uh from hanging
face I work in the open source team on
Transformers primarily and I'm slowly
getting converted to diffusion models
which is why I'm here today and I'd like
to introduce uh jono Whitaker who's the
creator of the course and he will talk a
little bit now about what the course is
about and then we'll dive in into the
talk with David so with that I'll let
you take over Jonathan great thank you
Lewis hello everybody and welcome to the
green face diffusion models class
um so this is
something that sprung up predominantly
because uh obviously you're all here
because diffusion models are this very
exciting kind of newly popular class of
models for generating things and so
everybody's excited about them and what
I think there was a big gap especially
when the first wave of excitement first
rose was that
um you know everyone's excited about
this but not too many people are able to
then take ownership of that and start
building on it because it's all quite
new so this costs me very excited just
to try and introduce these ideas to get
you up and running
um specifically on like using the
diffusers library in this case but just
more generally trying to understand the
different concepts from the basics all
the way up to something like stable
diffusion taking it fine-tuning it
adapting it and really understanding all
of the pieces that go into some big
complex system like this so at the
moment it's just unit one that's out
very much the introductory material but
hopefully enough to get you up to speed
with the core ideas and then from here
we're just going to build on and build
on probably every couple of weeks in
your unit and I think the first four are
listed but there's hopefully more in the
future as well as things like diffusion
for audio for example becomes more
mature and we're able to like capture
that into something that that's um with
with learning rather than something
that's too too rapidly changing so very
excited to share this with you all and
also super excited for today to um yeah
see what all of our guests have to share
with us
um which brings me I guess to
introducing the first speaker
so
um very much a warm welcome to David ha
until recently David was a researcher at
Google on the Google brain team in Japan
but just in the last few months he has
switched over and is now head of
strategy at stability AI so very excited
to hear from him and his his research
interests are you know complex systems
and self-organization and also just all
of these creative applications of
machine learning so David very great to
have you and I look forward to seeing
what you have to share with us
oh thank you I'm gonna share my slide
now uh can can you see my full screen
slide yes we can okay thanks uh thanks a
lot hug and face for intro uh for your
kind introduction and for letting me
give a talk just as a warning this uh
the rest of this uh today with the many
talks of like many technical talks but
this talk is going to be a general
non-technical talk because uh I've been
invited to give a general talk about
creative AI in this course uh so I'm
David ha I currently work at stability
AI
um and I joined around actually only one
and a half months ago and but somehow it
feels like a whole year has gone by this
this space is happening
um you know there's so much going on
right now things are you know going
really fast and before joining stability
AI I worked at Google brain as a
researcher for six years and you know in
this talk I I really want to dive in the
topic about collective intelligence and
how that is related to creative Ai and
the material in this block spraying from
a conversation between myself and my
collaborator Dr Judy fan who's a also a
machine learning and researcher but also
a psychologist in UCSD and also he's
going to Stanford next year and
basically with everything going on in uh
like I started doing machine learning
research around seven years ago and also
started working on Creative AI like
working on on generative models for
music and sketches and so on but it's
really that this year things really
started to explode with the Advent of
text to image models and diffusion
models and and things are happening at
such a fast speed that like I I always
questioned and I was discussing with
Judith earlier this year like like
what's what's going on we want to make
sense of it uh and and we we had lots of
discussions we dived into some of the
literature in in Behavioral Studies in
the past and I think we really have to
understand
how how people in general the population
or the collective intelligence is using
these Technologies and and interacting
with them to really understand how why
know things are Iraq going so rapidly
and things are being adapted and
such an exciting space so in this talk
I'm gonna mainly focusing on
on my experiences with this technology
and uh through understanding uh the
collective intelligence or how people
collectively use it it might help us
develop a framework for understanding
how these texture image models or more
broadly AI tools augments human creative
expression and they help us understand
why you know things are really taking
off this year so so let's let's dive in
so I I really like to study complex
systems and collective intelligence
because I think these systems are
beautiful and they lead to lots of like
resilience and robust properties one of
my favorite quotes is from this book
from Andrew Pickering in the cybernetic
brain where he he mentions uh Bridges
and buildings are all designed to be
indifferent to their environment to
withstand fracturations and not to adapt
to them the best bridge is one just just
stands there whatever the weather so I
think you know the the contrast between
a really well-built Bridge versus like a
bridge that's built by
a bunch of agents in this case ants that
were formed through through immersions
is a sharp one and and it's a metaphor
for what's going on in the technology
space right now so on one hand you have
a very large structured models that are
designed to do do things really well and
on the other hand like uh you can have
like like a open source models or or
people hundreds or thousands of people
hacking around models uh taking them
apart and making things out of them so I
think you know these two approaches are
is kind of like a at the core of what's
happening in the open source Community
right now and it's gonna be a theme of
this talk
and I when I think about image
generation from my collective
intelligence you know we can think about
Gans or vaes or stable diffusion but one
one one uh experiment I really like is
the image generation experiments uh
using humans as an algorithm on reddits
uh in in this art Place experiment so
this is if you haven't heard of our
place before it's it's basically
collective intelligence applied to image
generation uh it happens around once a
year on some years and they basically
set up a 1000 by 1000 pixel canvas so
there's a million pixels and each Reddit
user is only allowed to draw one pixel
every five minutes and the entire
experiment lasts for a week so so the
user uh in terms of the exploration
space has like a million times
256 possible color possibilities so
there's a wide range of exploration
space from the user's point of view the
user also wants to share and collaborate
with other users and and what's more
interesting is uh the the network
Dynamics also affects what is drawn as
well so there's three properties the the
exploration space there's also the the
drive to share and to to act in the
environments and for the user to to get
feedback from this complex network uh in
in this million pixel canvas so so what
happens is like um
the users on Reddit uh without any
explicit reward signal even coordinate
some strategy on the Reddit discussion
forum to to defend some design to attack
other designs and deform alliances and
this you know seemingly like a
non-objective test leads to these
awesome you know lots of these patterns
and resilience robustness going on and
and I I think you know this kind of
epitome optimizes uh many things that
are happening right now in the in the
diffusion models based in the open
source creative community so um I think
this this is something that
it really resonates with with what's
going on in in the in the machine
learning space as well
so the the
um if we talk about uh machine learning
in particular like generative AI
algorithms uh the collective
intelligence or like a collaborative uh
generative AI is not something that's so
new uh even back in 2007 uh Ken Stanley
published a paper called composition and
pattern producing Network or cppns uh
which are like a method to evolve neural
networks that can generate patterns and
and what he did back then was uh he he
put this algorithm on the internet back
then when there's not no JavaScript but
it was based on Java applets and he Let
it Loose so Ken Stanley and his
collaborators put this cppn algorithm on
the internet and users started to evolve
networks that generate these cool
patterns and what what is interesting
about these networks is some user can
take some of these networks and continue
to evolve them in some way so they can
they can kind of innovate and build on
top of them to generate other algorithms
as well so this leads to more and more
complex but interesting patterns being
discovered by by like a community of
users around this
platform which he called a pig breeder
so when I first got into machine
learning around seven years ago or seven
or eight years ago I played around with
this cppn algorithm as well and I
re-implemented it in JavaScript and this
is kind of how it looks like you evolve
a network on the rights you feed in the
the X and Y and the distance from the
center coordinate and the network
outputs the RGB value the color so in
principle this can generate very high
resolution images because you're not
confined with about how many pixels you
are you just put in the coordinates it
could be any coordinate you want and you
get a color and as these things
complexify I was able to generate very
complicated images that look kind of
cool and this was back in 2015 and like
when Gans or c410 was at 32 by 32
resolution and I thought it was kind of
cool to have a neural network generally
you know 2048 by 2048 pixel images
back then
so when I got into deep learning the
first thing I did was to apply this
cppns to MNS because I was sick and
tired of emness it was like 28 by 28
pixels it's so uninspiring and low
resolution so I immediately used these
methods to generate a thousand by
thousand pixel images of remnants
Stephen and also evolving all sorts of
abstract patterns using these cppns so I
was fascinated by looking at what has
been created from the from this sort of
a collective or communal AI algorithms
and how they can be applied to deep
learning
and later on uh when I joined Google and
I also worked with a team in called the
Google creative lab and they they also
built something very inspiring uh they
they built a viral game called Quick
Draw and they collected basically the
collective knowledge of how to do those
things on earth
using a quick draw game where basically
they have around like hundreds of
categories and users were asked to draw
things do those things in 20 seconds
that resembled that category and somehow
they collected hundreds of millions of
images for some reason people were
addicted to or or really enjoyed playing
with neural networks and this is a theme
that's kind of recurring right now as
well people like to have an interface to
work with an artificial neural network
just to see what happens with that
artificial neural network and they get
they like to get their feedback from
that artificial neural network so they
can they can play a game again
it's kind of like what's happening now
with the fusion models but that back
then it was a lot simpler and and here
you know the Google open source the data
sets of like tens of millions of these
Doodles uh and and it was pretty awesome
it was like the first large Collective
uh data set of Doodles all around the
globe
and you know of course me the first
thing I did was I took this data set and
and trained a generative model on it so
I trained the algorithm I recurrent
neural network called sketch RNN that
can that can take Doodles and and
continue to draw them uh for for the uh
so you can draw things like continue to
draw Gardens faces and insects and buses
and so fire trucks and so on and I I
really like playing around these uh
models interactively just like how now
when people use a diffusion models uh
you like to have a very short
feedback between seeing the output and
typing another prompt back then you know
these I made these models work in the
web browser so you get instant feedback
so after you finish drawing the machine
will take over right away and show you
what's going to happen next and I think
this this short feedback cycle is is
really important for a machine human HCI
uh when when we're trying to to get
people to creatively interact with these
algorithms I started playing around with
extending this to multiple inputs so
that you can you can see you can sample
different seeds like how when when
you're using diffusion models now you
don't just you generate one you want to
generate 9 or 16 and choose the best
stuff so so this is kind of like back
then you want to generate a lot of these
and get inspiration from as as many
Randomness as possible
uh and and just like now uh back then I
I also tried to open source these models
and release it for everyone to use and
it was just amazing to see how the
community took apart all of these neural
networks in the wild and and one of the
things I saw was that people deployed
them uh on on robots and they were
drawing Doodles of cats and birds and
and even someone took the sketch RNA
model and projected some outputs to to a
building and you know like that was
pretty cool uh so uh what was really
interesting uh back then was that even
in 2018 2019
um the there was a student at Berkeley
Forest Wong who who actually uh looked
at Quick Draw data set and sketch RNN
and and use uh the concepts of prompts
and put them into embeddings and and he
he had a paper that took a short text
description and and tried to create a
doodle based on that description so this
is a very rudimentary version of modern
texture image but it was text to Doodles
and I think one of the the things I
liked was that Doodles were really
simple so he didn't need that much
resources to train this model and and
able to to you know like test out these
early versions of text to image
algorithms uh of course three years
later the world has completely changed
but I thought this was a pretty cool
work back then before texture images
really took off so around that time you
know I was working on many research
problems and
and fast forward a few years
you know just from from April of this
year
um to when when open AI Google started
demoing their text image models I I had
a fantastic experience playing around
with text image models uh you may you
may look at my Twitter and my Twitter
repeat was full of these examples so so
I I really like to play around with
Daddy too and imagine at the beginning
um I when I started using daddy 2 and
imagine I I knew this was gonna be a
game changer it's going to change your
world like I I actually thought they
were a bigger deal than pure text
generation models like GPT because
somehow the you know the human
perception system uh the visual system
is so attached to our senses to to our
inner self that we we feel a lot more uh
motivated and you have a stronger
emotional response when we when we look
at the images compared to reading text
and and I think uh you know that there's
there's a too many uh like two types of
uh initial applications that people were
making arts uh using these models and
also making making photos of weird stuff
like a photograph of a strawberry frog
and what was really weird uh it seems it
was only this year but it seems like so
many so such a long time ago that like
remember back in April only a small
minority of people had access to Daddy
too or imagen
um I I remember back then it's not like
now everyone can download stable
diffusion or whatnot or get get invites
to the journey but like I I was only a
handful of people in the world who had
access to Daddy to an Imogen and it felt
weird it's it's like there's only a
small number of users and I felt like
something was was weird and kind of
wrong because I think this amazing
technology should just be be available
to everyone but you know I had access to
it so I played around with it and um I
started off making images like like many
of you with known artistic style like
having cyberpunk digital art or or
making Banksy images of Totoro uh then I
tried to create some images of some
degree of realism uh but it's kind of
like a fantasy like like the robots
romance or or beers like Bears drinking
beer and eating Ramen and Shinjuku these
were kind of cool uh and and then you
can try to create some images with some
degree of emotion which which is
possible because of a diverse data sets
and embeddings and you can have like you
know robot stating or cats trading on
the stock market and so on
and what what I what I captivated me
about these models is their ability to
learn abstraction so one one of my
motivation on the earlier sketch RNN and
quick draw experiment was I wanted to
understand how humans like ourselves
develop abstract concepts of things and
then we do the very simple
representations of those things but
somehow these models can just learn that
like we can ask the daddy to to to
create a minimal line joint of New York
City and it does that it can create like
Lego figures of Jay-Z Jeff Bezos Arnold
Schwarzenegger and Rihanna and it has to
kind of learn some abstract
representation of Rihanna or Jeff Bezos
or Jay-Z to to make Lego figures from
them so I think these are pretty
convincing example that they're able to
learn abstractions uh I you know as you
know I I post a lot of these images on
social media earlier this year and I
kind of monitor some of the engagement I
noticed that the images with the highest
engagements are often not the ones that
look the most beautiful or realistic
like like good art doesn't get retreated
that much is is the ones that have have
involved cultural factors or kind of
memes so like one one of the the my
favorite one is this photograph of a
bare stock market in the 1930s as you
know this year stuck for stocks and
everyone's losing money and and you know
I tweeted that out and uh the fact that
the bear Market got interpreted as a
bear uh and then the market was actually
going down you know made this popular
made this image with this kind of a
misinterpretation really popular and the
Bitcoin was also tanking and somehow I
was like people like Japanese art so
Japanese yukilte scrolls with Bitcoin
was also a trending thing
and these models were also great at
making novel combinations of very
distant Concepts like no one expects
Darth Vader to be on the cover of Vogue
magazine and and maybe no one expects
like maybe some of you about Darth Vader
at a Tech conference you know maybe he's
trying to pitch some deal in in a bad
Market environment
and uh one of the things that really
shows the the Brilliance of the
community is the ability to reverse
engineer uh close models like I'm sure
many of you know that Daddy too has some
uh the safeguards or or like limitations
uh or where you can't type in profanity
and some users not me like type things
like you know [ __ ] you and get Elmo to
to generate that as a text image it's
kind of funny and uh and people also
reverse engineer uh how uh the the
system was inserting prompts into the
algorithm so they they had a problem
that says a person holding a sign that
says and then suddenly the there will be
a sign that says female or black uh as a
way to debias some of the images so the
community is pretty smart humans are
pretty smart as a group to to figure
stuff out
so by by June of this year I was
thinking what's next right these are
pretty amazing stuff this is the was at
that time I was thinking what is the
future of text to image models dominated
by uh big companies like open AI Google
who have the resources to train bigger
models on bigger data sets
and there's a plot twist
um in the middle of this year uh there's
a huge spike in the usage of this model
called daily mini so Daddy mini uh is uh
is a community effort funded by a hug
and face I think it's a hackathon by
Boris and led by Boris and they try to
reproduce daddy one and they were
successful you know they created the
model that can generate stuff from text
generate images from text that it's not
a high resolution it's like 256 by 256
and hug and face served this model uh on
on the hug and face gradio or whatever
the demo and it became a viral hits uh
what was amazing is uh it's at some
point this year daddy two not Daddy mini
became an absolute viral internet meme
like you know we're on ML Twitter and ml
Reddit and so on but none of that
matters like look like much broader than
that people actually like Associated
text to image with Daddy too and many
people were kind of surprised by that
but it turns out that Daddy too because
of the low resolution and the three by
three grid is is great at making memes
like you know Eminem as an m m it
actually makes an m m as an m m so
people people loved it it gotten so
popular at one point that the the New
Yorker made a cartoon that featured this
iconic 3x3 grid uh in on the tweets and
and it was it was written up on on
Newsweek because you're able to to make
funny images of trump and Biden using
daddy too which which was probably
prohibited from Daddy uh I'm using daddy
mini which is probably prohibited from
Daddy too
so people even made a meme for this
daddy mini like uh I I like at the
beginning daily mini daddy 2 was rolled
out to a selected group of artists but
then at the same time people started
using data to make minions at Cross
burning
jar jar brings that Nuremberg Trial and
and doing things like gender review 911
but it's kind of funny and I think when
Daddy 2 came out it really offers a hint
of creativity of the masses being
Unleashed and and this sort of a casual
creativity is something that's really
apparent in these texture image models
like like people can take these Concepts
like gender reveal and make death star
explosion gender reveal a funeral at
Walmart or neurosurgeons putting Ramen
inside a man's head as a joke and it
would generate it and this is hilarious
and I think you know what what made
these viral is it's these models are
it's not just about scaling the model
size or compute I mean that's important
to get some quality but just as
importantly I think uh the success of
daddy mini is about scaling the number
of human users and developers that's
using this stuff like there's like an
evolutionary approach like people play
with this model and upload their
favorite ones and the community will
upvote the ones that they think are the
most popular and hence you get these
these meme images that come out on top
so and what's also Apparent at the time
many of you know now is like what works
on one model does not work on others
like when you type in YouTuber doing a
funeral unboxing on daily mini it's
pretty funny stuff you get this like you
know Tech Pro unboxing uh uh like a
funeral uh like a coffin but if you put
the same problem in daddy too it doesn't
really work right so so these images uh
the best images are are actually a
result of not just the model but a
complex feedback loop between a human uh
or or the community of humans and a
neural network model
so
um another issue uh thing that made that
mini popular is because it's it can be
used to portray cultural items to
reflect current issues like you know
this year people generated a fixture
price my first hand grenade or Supreme
Court dressed as clowns that you can
probably it's self-explanatory and and
like when I was discussing this with my
collaborator uh Judy I think like this
we think there's many uh we can distill
it down to three processes there's the
motivation to share so after exploration
uh using a text image model we want to
people want to share them and through
sharing the images in multiple variants
you get some feedback from the network
that you share too and and think people
build build on top of it so there's
really there we think there's three
stages in this framework there's
individual exploration stage of using
the tool or the model to create an
artifact there's a drive to share and
and there's a network of dynamics that
will allow people to build on top of
your Innovation just like the pick
breeder experiment or cppn experiment I
discussed at the beginning of this talk
and then you get the feedback back to
the user so the first uh is many
enhancing the person's ability to
efficiently explore a wide space of
possibilities like individual
exploration there's also the the model
or the the the the framework or the like
text image model is basically heightens
a person strive to share what they have
created with other people maybe because
text image models is just so new and
cool people just want to share these
things maybe it won't be the case in 10
years from now or probably not and
number three
the important thing is unlocking the
feedback dynamics that accelerate
Innovations across large communities so
you share them and you get feedback
whether on social media or or whatnot
and an example of this is like these
Innovations in the model are learned and
passed on other users and are built upon
like people discovered that daily mini
was good at drawing sketches of
courtrooms so on dinosaur and people
copy this concept and made a bottle of
ranch dressing testifying in court or
alien appearing in court for damages
caused by abductions this is pretty
hilarious people discovered that
PlayStation is pretty good as well it's
Grand Theft Auto 10 and square Edition
and American Psycho for PS2
so this is only one part of the puzzle I
think so there's the individual creator
of artists using these tools uh we also
think this framework can be applied more
broadly so
um there in this space there's the users
and creators and artists using these uh
texture image models or AI tools to
create artifacts there's also the
developers that are working on these
models or new ways to use these models
or app applications and and hence
creating applications as an artifact as
well and also uh sometimes the artists
can also be the developer so they can
wear multiple hats but there's also so
there's like these two layers of of
Loops going on and not just users but
also Developers
uh so I'm gonna talk about uh disparts
using stable diffusion as a case study
where we see things like creative
applications model hackers and research
and boy the you know the we can step
from daily mini to stay with the fusion
Community it's basically going from AI
memes to AI Arts like I think I have
about 5-10 minutes left because it's
okay so like uh the the to stay with the
fusion Community is not just satisfied
with text image they want to create arts
and fantastic images from it and boy
this community is weird like you you get
on the left like the the model like uh
the the model hackers that want to to
Really make things look perfect and kind
of criticize every single flaw you get
the normal users that just wants to make
memes like Paris into Hilton and Albert
Einstein you know being wet to each
other and you also get the developers
like people hacking on dreambooth to
make pictures of their friend's wedding
uh so I'm going to talk about these
three uh these three categories and of
this group so in in the area of creative
developers uh because the model is open
source uh it led to things like you know
like hundreds of apps like Photoshop
figma blender and people writing plugins
for all of these apps and it's really
difficult for one company to build
plugins for everything you really need a
community of hundreds of thousands of
developers like within days of stable
diffusion initial launch people were
building
uh people build up a figma plug-in that
you can just use the stable diffusion
model type in a text prop in in Sigma
and then you would you would get like
the the the realistic looking looking
design uh from from a text to prompt and
conditioned on on on an SVG drawing or
like a rendered SVG trying uh blender as
well people were able to quickly develop
plugins or various plugins for stable
division for blender because blender is
the open source standard tool for
creating 3D scenes people are able to
take these like renderings and 3D
wireframe images type in a text prompt
and make them into various you know real
like art pieces using stable diffusion
and like the the other part I was
talking about is the model hackers
there's so many model hackers out there
uh and this community really discovered
novel ways of using stable diffusion
things like negative prompts how to
combine models fine-tuning to model
distillation like I think uh negative
prompts I I I'm not sure what it where
it was discovered but it was certainly
made popular in stable diffusion like
you type in the prompts that you don't
want to uh to see and suddenly it makes
your Burgers look much better you can we
can chain together daily mini to stable
division models because maybe that
immunity is creates more meme images and
you can create a higher quality version
of gaming toilet made from Nvidia RTX
3090 gpus
there's also a whole bunch of hackers
making fine-tuning custom models using
dreambooth or other techniques to
customize models or on a particular data
set and this is something only possible
with open source models because with a
closed Source but very large model it's
probably it probably doesn't know who
you are or probably doesn't know any
some Niche concept where like you
actually want a smaller model that's
good enough and you can just fine tune
it on on your your small data set to it
to have a like a diffusion model that's
that's too suitable for your particular
application
and and what's funny is uh people
actually like uh try to get stable
diffusion to generate styles that look
like literally by by simply like
collecting mid-journey images and and
fine-tuning stable diffusion model to to
mimic the prompt to mid-journey images
and you can kind of get uh mid-journing
uh you can they kind of discovered the
concept of model distillation
rediscovered it by fine-tuning uh stable
diffusion into with journey data that
was kind of cool and then lastly I I
think I I'll go two minutes left I'll
talk about how I think open source
diffusion models like stable division uh
will become a foundation of the research
Community there's so many works right
now that's actually using stable
diffusion as The Benchmark model to
communicate results uh in in the
academic community and in the research
Community as a whole like for instance
there's this amazing paper called dream
of many of you may have used it to fine
tune your stable delusion models it came
out by this fantastic group from Google
research I know everyone here and
like it was originally written to be
used with the image and model inside
Google but right now if you say dream
Booth people will automatically think
that you're using dream proof with
stable diffusion because it's it's what
works out there and because of the open
source model
another recent cool work is this
instruct fix to picks uh written written
from Tim Brooks and his collaborators at
Berkeley and they they were able to
combine a GPT type model or language
model with stable diffusion to be able
to to create to instruct uh the the
model how to edit the images using
natural language and I think these are
things that are easily doable you know
with open source model compared to a
large closed Source model
uh even in the area of uh
interpretability in machine learning
people are using stable division as a
base when communicating uh you know like
the results like they're using uh that
someone wrote a paper on interpreting
and stay with the vision with attention
maps and so on and I think that Robin
they talk about this later in this talk
but we think that stable division is
also going to become a popular model of
choice for machine learning researchers
working with diffusion models and we
think that the base model to conduct
research on will become something like
stable division or an open source model
because precisely it's open source we
actually think a stable division it will
probably become something like a vgg or
Alex net model in the academic and
Industry ml research Community because
people can communicate and speak in the
same language
and even lastly some some areas outside
of ml research like Health are using
stable diffusion there's a paper called
a Rowan gen or someone built a team
build a generative model uh by
fine-tuning stable diffusion on a large
X-ray and Radiology report data set and
they're they're creating new
generating new X-ray and Radiology
images using like new like by modifying
the text prompt so I'm not sure whether
how impactful that is but this stuff is
going on and I think I don't want to go
out of time but I think this is just the
beginning and I think with the
trajectory of this open source and
community-led development both on the
user side on the developer side and the
research side the future is going to be
really bright so I don't want to go out
of time thank you
right
there we go
that's uh awesome talk uh I think maybe
the most number of like memes like
actual memes
um I've seen in a talk so uh really
really cool
um we've got a few questions from the
audience if you if you've got a few
minutes
um to sure I don't want to go over time
because I I think uh maybe we're still
under time yeah just to see so there's
one here maybe you can choose one shoot
one or two and I can answer them so the
first question is from IQ mates who's
asking are these models as these models
become more capable how do we protect
against deep fakes and I think this is
like a really important question that is
on the mind of you know everyone worried
about generative AI I think so too like
uh like there's many opinions out there
uh but the my opinion and my view is
like uh we should release these models
as frequently as possible to the
community and I think that the community
like at large will be able to look at
the dangers of these models or or
preventing defects and looking at the
dangers collectively and finding ways to
mitigate them I I think this approach is
much preferable than having one
institution taking the responsibility of
protecting the model because there's so
many there's so many instances of
History where like that doesn't work
like look at cryptography yeah and so on
now why are these models are not that
like perfectly realistic generating you
know hands with six fingers I say just
release them put them out there get
people to to work on safety aspects
collectively and and I think that the
red team has to be in the open source
world as well uh to work together with
the model development team uh to to like
uh push forward otherwise uh like um you
would just end up confining a model
inside an organization and it'll never
see the light of day and that model will
eventually be believed somehow or people
will reproduce it with once it's very
high quality and people would the
community will not have enough time to
develop
um the the protection against it
yeah that's totally great I think I'm
also at hiking face this is something
that we're very aligned with about you
know doing things in the open right
because what we learned also in NLP is
that when you have open source language
models people can actually then inspect
them and you know attack them which is
cool right I mean it's not easy to do
through an APA
yeah totally and as I discussed in the
last part of the slides the
interpretability research are using
stable diffusion models as the best
model yeah so this is actually happening
right now
cool so maybe we could take one more
question which is a bit of a eye to the
Future so um will text to GIFS or text
to videos become the natural extension
to the sort of current family of
generative models or is this still a
difficult problem to solve
I I think it's a natural extension like
uh if if you follow the literature uh
Google has already published a email gen
video uh work and that that's pretty
awesome you know I used it when I was
there you know it works
and it's only a matter of time when
these results get reproduced by the
community at large and extended upon and
then like uh hopefully uh when like the
way I approach research or we approach
research as stability AI is not
necessarily just reproducing stuff where
we want to be able to innovate and
optimize for efficiency like like where
you don't actually need like a TPU pod
to run these models and we want to make
sure that maybe we need a decent GPU
might work uh the quality might not be
state-of-the-art but at least people can
try to make gifts from it exactly
I think it was you who said on Twitter
that like the the metric today is like
can it run on collab and then how many
images per second it's like yeah
so it's it's a it's a multi-objective
optimization I think when we're making
these models and we just gotta get the
best bang for the buck
awesome so maybe we can uh in the
broadcast there so uh thank you so much
David for joining us it's been a real
pleasure
um thank you I really enjoyed the talk
and um to everyone else who's in the
audience we're going to take a break now
and we'll be back uh at six o'clock uh
central eastern time so catch you later
foreign